in this video i want to talk to you
about a time where i bombed completely
bombed
a stage presentation and one of the most
important lessons that i've learned from
it that has made me a lot of money since
then um and has protected my reputation
and gotten me a lot of goodwill
so if you've ever like not known what to
do or what to offer people or hey should
i try and use this as an opportunity to
build goodwill or forge a relationship
or should i try and you know sell
something or get a margin on this i want
to tell you a couple different stories
that kind of all illustrate the same
point that i've learned over the last
few years all right and so um one of my
favorite uh kind of like bullets on this
that you can you can write or downer is
uh no half measures right uh either sell
or don't sell
but don't be in between and so the first
time that this kind of happened for me
was i was uh asked to speak at this kind
of high level uh mastermind which
happens relatively frequently um but
this one in particular was a it was a
fitness related one um and uh for me
when i have presentations and stuff i
usually spend a long time preparing
sometimes i'll make a product actually
that was the only time i made a product
but i spent a long time on the
presentation so it's usually a big deal
for me to say yes because it's like i'm
gonna have to i'm gonna have to do a lot
of work on my side um and so
anyways i had this uh this this this
presentation in this pitch that i had
made for a product that we had made
specifically for this audience and when
i got there they had given me a three
hour time slot all right which is insane
and i think part of that was because
they just wanted to have me talk as long
as possible you know for their audience
because they thought it would be
valuable and so for whatever reason i
agreed um and the thing is is like you
can't pitch for three hours or maybe you
can but you can't straight pitch for
three hours right and so what i decided
to do is just provide you know a lot of
value you know near the end after two
and a half hours i was like i'll just
kind of mention what we have going on
right
and so i get up there first off uh the
the audience size is one-third of what
was what i was told so i was like okay
that's a little bit different and
disheartening i go and i you know piece
by piece i'm doing q a with the audience
all that kind of stuff right and so as
we transition um or as we as i
transition to the pitch part right
i uh i pull up the the slide deck that's
normally a you know a 90 minute slide
presentation um with a pitch and an
offer and everything
and i went through it and i was like
yeah yeah we talked about this and i'm
going through the slides right like like
super fast just being like yep and this
you guys don't need me to tell you the
story right you should understand this
boom boom boom and then at the very end
i i basically make the pitch right
without any kind of pre-frame and i go
through it just like really fast and
kind of half-assed
and um i bombed
it was horrendous it was horrible
because i had so much speaking time they
didn't take me off stage because i still
had like time left and so i'm sitting
there on stage having made the offer no
one's moved and then people were and
then all of a sudden ra hand star racing
from the audience with with questions
and i had never
sold anything that was cheap in my life
so this was a two thousand dollar thing
it was literally the first time in my
entire life at first on anything below
16 000 um
you know which is which was you know for
our
into the fitness space right i thought
this was like a no-brainer it's too
grand either i mean just
buy it and then make a ton more money
because it's it's stupid right i started
having people be like hey can i can i do
a payment plan on the two thousand
dollars i remember
be like if you need a payment plan then
uh don't buy it
and next question and someone's like i
feel like um you know the supplements
that you have are against my
my goodwill because we i only promote
vegan things and i was like cool then
don't buy it and this is how the
questions start unrolling like this vibe
this toad right and you could just watch
the plane just going towards the ground
on fire burning right i do this for like
30 more minutes all right of q a of me
just getting increasingly annoyed
because hey there's only like 30 people
there which there was supposed to be a
lot more than that anyways and so i
remember
the feeling i had afterwards which was
just like anger and embarrassment and
just like you know humiliate all of
those you know at once and mind you like
at the time and this is then right we
were doing about four million a month
all right and so when i had some people
were like well how do we know it's gonna
like gonna work for a fitness house like
i have 4 000 freaking locations here
like that use this licensing model i
paired it down just for you guys so that
you can use the materials at a
at one-eighth the price this is not a
discussion right
so anyways
i remember sitting there and in the pain
of the moment and the humiliation i was
like what am i going to learn from this
which may be in and of itself something
that you might be able to take with you
but like whenever you have those like
super emotional moments right
i know from my conversations with dr
cashy that when you have extreme
emotions you're actually in in hyper
learning mode ptsd is where you're
basically you turn your brain on and it
goes into hyper learning mode because
there's trauma that is going around you
right and or you know there's it's a
traumatic experience which just means
super heightened emotions and so what
happens is your brain says learn from
this right and then it starts ingraining
these things so that when you hear loud
noises then you get amped and then etc
right and so it's the same kind of thing
so if you have these emotional moments
this is for me this is what i do is i
try and think like what am i going to
try and ingrain in my brain right now
because i have an opportunity to hyper
learn something in these moments
and so the lesson i learned and i'll
tell you another story in a second that
really drove this home no half measures
either pitch or don't pitch all right so
if you go into a business meeting or you
go to a conference or you go to a
whatever right
either ask hard or do not ask at all
there is no half-assed asking all right
and this is a lesson that i have learned
hard i actually had one of my uh one of
my exacts he ended up pitching this is
you know now that we've moved ourselves
out of that business and now we're just
on top of it one of the the execs in my
gym business he half pitched something
to our audience he like half pitches
like you guys don't need me to do the
scarcity thing right you guys don't need
me to do these guarantees right you
don't need me to do these actually these
bonuses right and i was like what are
you doing i remember because the i was
like that is how you pitch you're saying
that they don't need all the things that
persuade them he's like well they know
because we teach them how to do this
stuff and i was like yeah but like
people still need it to make decisions
and so he bombed that and he learned the
lesson himself so my goal is that you
don't have to bomb it uh to learn the
lesson right and so let me tell you the
upside of this here's the flip side
right so i talked about just now how you
can how like no half measures either
pitch or don't pitch right don't go in
the middle
i think one of the one of the things
that's difficult for entrepreneurs is to
know when to make the ask right so it's
like okay well if i'm either going all
in or all out well then how do i know
when to do which right
and i would say that most times
i have been better served in my life by
holding back my ask
and what i mean by that and this is like
a super life hack so for those of you
who are who are who are perseverant and
focused on what i'm saying right now
then take this in
if you get to a point of good will if
you keep giving and keep giving and keep
giving you don't need to ask ever
you will just get
so
there's there's the commonly you know
told like you know uh jab jab jab right
hook right give give give ask right
but i will i would postulate that there
is another one that is even more
powerful which is give give give
give give give give give get give give
give give get give give get right is
that people will just start handing
things to you because humans are
reciprocal in nature they believe that
if they are getting something at a
certain point they must reciprocate
somehow which is why the spammers who
copy my name on this channel do so well
with my channel because i don't ask for
anything from mozy nation so by the way
just another disclaimer i will not dm
you or put you on whatsapp and ask you
for cab fare or ask you to buy something
everything that i have is free here so
just fyi just as a reminder to everybody
and a lot of the best things that i've
had happen in my life have come from
goodwill and so i think the biggest
difference between big business owners
and small business owners
is that they do not understand and apply
the concept of goodwill right and i'll
do an entire thing on goodwill next time
because it's a deep topic that i love
talking about but right now in your
business you have the opportunity to
provide things for your audience and if
you can continue to provide them and
have the patience to wait for the ask
you can actually make significantly more
money all right and so the thing is is
if you're going to make the ask which
means if you're going to withdraw from
your your relational capital right the
goodwill that you have in your audience
if you're going to make the withdrawal
then ask and ask hard and mean it it's
not the time to make it a nickel here a
nickel there a nickel there right it's
so much better to just keep investing
keep over delivering and then when you
ask make it known that you are asking
and that is one of the biggest lessons
that i have learned over time in
business for me is that it is so much
better to give and keep giving and keep
giving and oftentimes you will get and
if you pitch which you if like the idea
is to ideally never even have to because
you should be getting so much but if you
if you must pitch then pitch like you
mean it right and don't have asset so
anyways that was a story of my bombing i
hope you uh
found some humor in that uh for my
humiliation um mosey nation love you all
uh my name is oxford mosey i have i i
own acquisition.com which is portfolio
of companies uh and uh i have absolutely
nothing to sell you so
if you enjoyed this hit the subscribe
button and i will see you guys in the
next video a lot of people are broke and
i don't want you to be one of them which
is why i make this channel keeping
awesome lots of love bye